on may 30th 1938 accountant carl wilks
married christilda berryman in
bakersfield california just one year
later
they gave birth to their son paul emery
wilkes but on april 1 1943 they would
return to the bakersfield receiving
hospital
this time to deliver a daughter but this
was no april fool's joke annie wilkes is
the main antagonist of stephen king's
misery a character he created to
represent his fear of his most obsessive
fans but annie's history goes much
deeper than what we see in the film
adaptation of misery so stick around to
the end of this video to see me analyze
her entire life story
including how she planned to take
revenge on paul after escaping the house
this video is sponsored by raycon quick
note i've been doing a lot of serious
looking into the best options for
premium wireless earbuds and it doesn't
make
any sense to me why anyone would look
past the raycon everyday e25 earbuds
they have the perfect fit for your ears
and deliver that top-notch clean
isolated sound quality that you'd expect
from the top brands on the market
i'm gonna get back to the video right
now but i just don't get why you would
spend 200
or more when you could use my link right
now to get ray cons and you'll be
getting better battery life six hours of
play time and great color options visit
buy raycon dot com slash cz's world to
get that deal
as a young girl annie loved going to the
movies with her brother and her favorite
part was always the chapter plays in the
1940s television was not yet widespread
and the internet did not yet exist so
the feature films were accompanied by
newsreels and serials or as annie called
them chapter plays her favorite series
was called rocketman well it may have
actually been called king of the rocket
man annie's memory tends to be a little
bit spotty
she loved the cliffhangers at the end of
each episode and would spend the week
thinking about how rocketman would get
out of his latest dilemma in one episode
rocketman was stuck in a car with no
brakes that went over the cliff bursted
into flames and fell into the ocean
the next week annie was there early to
see how it turned out but was furious to
see rocketman jump out of the car just
before it went over the cliff
i stood right up and started shouting
this isn't what happened last week
have you all got amnesia they just
cheated us
this isn't fair he didn't get out of the
cock-a-doody car
she wouldn't stop yelling about how that
wasn't what happened last week to the
point that the manager threatens to kick
her out
this incident tells us two things about
annie first it highlights her obsessive
attitude towards works of fiction
a problem that will only intensify as
she gets older and discovers new stories
to latch onto
second it shows the early signs of
borderline personality disorder she's
sitting there excited for the movie one
minute and
causing a scene the next she has no
control over her emotions and mood
swings
annie was also a long time sugar junkie
maybe another sign of her lack of
self-discipline
sometimes she babysat for a woman who
lived in her building named mrs kremetz
but she didn't like the four kids and
called them the brats
on october 28th 1954 when annie was 11
her family was staying in a temporary
house because of a water leak in the
apartment and annie went back and
started a fire in the basement
killing five people including the brats
that she had to babysit this was an
extreme response
showing us that annie's views on other
people were very black and white
she either liked someone and practically
worshipped them or deemed them bad
and felt that they didn't deserve to
live there was very little in between
unfortunately for her father carl wilkes
he fell into the latter category on july
19
1957 he passed away at 44 years of age
newspapers reported him stumbling on a
pile of clothing but it's heavily
implied that his 14 year old daughter
had something to do with this
the next incident came january 29th
1962. annie was in her sophomore year at
usc's nursing school when her roommate
andrea st
james was taken out in a similar manner
she had supposedly tripped on their cat
which was lying on the stairs
ending her life at 21 years of age it
was discovered that the cat had also
been poisoned but that didn't seem
suspicious because the landlord had put
out rat traps in the basement and
figured that the cat had gotten into
them
perhaps one of the most disturbing parts
about annie's minimum of eight victims
before
even graduating from college is the fact
that there was a sense of pride that she
associated with her accomplishments she
collected newspaper articles for each of
the obituaries she was responsible for
and secretly kept them in her scrapbook
often looking back at them as her
cherished memories right there with
other normal achievements like her
graduation from nursing school on may 17
1966
she was in honor students the first
nursing job she held was across the
country in manchester new hampshire
where she continued to collect
obituaries at st
joseph's hospital her first victim there
was a 79 year old ernest ghonian
followed not long after by hester queen
ebulifund
there were three deaths that summer then
two more in the fall of 1969 so during
that year in new hampshire she had
nearly doubled her victim count i would
attribute this to desensitization
her attacks in her child and teen years
were very spaced out but the more she
did it the more frequent her issues
became
then once she was in nursing school she
was around death a lot more and got even
more used to it for most people this
wouldn't be a problem but for someone
with bpd in addition to a secret violent
past it could be considered an issue i
would like to point out that the
desensitization that i'm talking about
is not the same as desensitization to
violence in movies video games or other
media which is proven to have no link to
real world violence
each of her hospital victims were older
people whose deaths were attributed to
long illness or in some cases short
illness perhaps due to paranoia that
people were catching on she decided to
start in a fresh new town
a career reboot if you will but like
many horror franchises today annie's
life had way
too many reboots and yes i'm looking at
you
it started on march 19th 1970 when she
was announced as a new registered nurse
at riverview hospital in harrisburg
pennsylvania this was followed by
another two patients that she gave the
old you don't get to be alive anymore
treatment too you know annie is scary
when i'm running out of words to use
that won't get me in trouble with
youtube
it was also in harrisburg where she took
up karate and apparently was very good
at it
i would guess that this is also where
she gained a lot of her strength and
part of the reason that she's able to
easily carry a fully grown man when
she's in her mid-40s annie also took up
a hobby in collecting ceramic figures
her last victim in harrisburg was a
three-year-old who had fallen down a
well and was already in a coma so it
didn't look that suspicious when annie
was
unable to save the kid at this point she
basically got into a cycle she'd get a
job in a new city collect two or three
more victims and then move on before
anyone started to catch on what she was
up to
but the reason she didn't stay may not
have been just because of her growing
list of victims she was also secretly
stealing medication and stashing it for
her own personal use
but i knew enough not to take any of the
morphine-based drugs
they lock those up they count they keep
records and if they get an idea that a
nurse is
you know chipping that's what they call
it they will watch that nurse until
they're sure
the non-canon fan series castle rock
suggests that she stole medications to
relieve her hallucinations but there's
no confirmation of that in the novel her
pattern continued until 1978 when she
started a job at the denver receiving
hospital
annie's first victim in denver was a
woman named laura rothberg in september
of 1978. but the next headline would not
be an obituary but rather
a marriage announcements
[Music]
ralph dugan was a physical therapist at
arapahoe county hospital and according
to paul sheldon he looked a lot like
annie wilkes father
marrying a parent-like figure has come
up a lot in king's writing i discussed
similar relationships when analyzing
characters like beverly marsh and eddie
casbrack annie relocated an hour
northwest to the small town of nederland
where ralph's hospital was located
together they bought a house in
sidewinder on march 3rd 1979
and during the time that she was with
ralph she didn't add any obituaries to
her collection
someone with borderline personality
disorder may try to use a relationship
as a source of comfort to their symptoms
the same way that struggling people
might turn to drugs or alcohol so i
think this may have contributed to her
break period from the violence
unfortunately ralph was a physical
therapist not a mental one
so leaning on a relationship was
probably not a healthy way for her to
deal with her issue
kimberly holland writes on healthline
that even common bpd symptoms can be
detrimental to a relationship
and that these endeavors are often
short-lived ralph and annie lasted only
a year and a half and on august 3rd 1980
ralph filed for a divorce on the grounds
of mental cruelty paul suggests that
ralph might have even realized her true
nature
and luckily gotten out of there while he
still had his life another note on the
bpd and relationships article states
that the person can become very angry
and hurt over something that a person
without bpd would not react to
they can even become obsessive however
as far as we can tell annie does not
necessarily become obsessive about her
ex-husband but rather
focuses on her other true love fiction
more specifically she's found a new
favorite author
his name was paul sheldon and annie
adored his period romance novel series
the misery books misery had become her
new obsession annie also loved pigs and
even named her newest addition to the
barn after misery's titular character
paul say hello to my favorite beast in
the whole world
i sow misery
misery and i think after finding out
that the author traditionally finished
his novels nearby in boulder colorado
the object of her obsession turned from
misery to him and she relocated her job
one last time to a hospital in boulder
by the time she started that job in
march 1981
she had taken back her maiden name annie
dugan was once again annie wilkes
it would also seem that her anger over
the failed marriage was taken out on her
patients in boulder and in 1981 she made
up for her lost time by taking 13 more
victims from may until the end of the
year bringing her total up over 30. but
the most disgusting of her crimes were
yet to come
on january 14 1982 she was named as the
new head maternity nurse and it only
took her two weeks to extend her
tradition onto the newborn
infants that were kept there the first
incident took place on january 29th with
another that followed not long after
when paul eventually reads about the
newborn obituaries in annie's scrapbook
he thinks that she probably started only
going after babies with birth defects
and eventually expanded it to include
the healthy ones as well
this theory makes sense because she at
one point demonstrates to paul that she
believes in putting creatures out of
their misery when she kills an injured
rat but she later shows evidence of a
growing taste for violence when she
re-injures paul after noticing that he's
starting to heal
in mid-march there were five more
nursery deaths and this time an
investigation is launched
we are going to be launching an
investigation
into what happened i told him that we
were launching an investigation
previously she was always able to get
away before her actions were
investigated but this time she wasn't
able to do so and i can see two reasons
first the fact that she was dealing with
infants this time as opposed to elderly
people
it's not that unusual for an elderly
person to get sick and pass away and
while newborns are lost from time to
time it doesn't make sense for so many
healthy babies to kick the buckets the
second reason goes back to her
short-lived marriage with ralph
it's much easier to pick up and leave
unexpectedly if you're renting an
apartment but since she owned the house
now it would be much harder to move not
to mention
more suspicious but the amazing part
about this junction in her history is
that the investigation didn't discourage
her from continuing
on march 24th she made a statement on
behalf of the hospital saying that the
culprit may have been tainted baby
formula but in april another infant hit
zero hp and in may two more little
chunkers took dirt naps instead of
nursery naps
by june 1st they were closing in on
annie and she underwent questioning by
her own free will
they eventually let her go and maybe
that close call got her to back off
temporarily
because there were no infant cases in
june but she started back up again in
early july with three more
little tiny funerals on july 19th annie
was arrested for the murder of girl
christopher one of the victims that
actually lived long enough to be given a
name annie was given a nickname by the
press the dragon lady because of the
nature of the situation where the entire
village was basically after her with
torches and pitchforks the best evidence
against her was a hand mark on the
child's throat with what seemed to be
the mark of annie's ring the jury made
their verdict on december 13th
and in the newspaper was a photograph of
annie quietly reading her copy of
misery's quest
inside her holding cell the dragon lady
was found innocent much to the dismay of
the town
she parted ways with the hospital
putting an end to what would be her last
job but that does not mean that she'd
put out her last victim in late 1983 she
picked up a hitchhiker named andrew
pomeroy on the way back from a ceramic
show
pomeroy told her he was headed to
sidewinder on assignment from a magazine
in new york
he was to go make some sketches of the
ruins of a place called the overlooked
hotel which had been burned down 10
years beforehand by a crazy caretaker
those of you who have read the shining
will be familiar with this location
there are often cross-references to
other stories in king's writing but this
connection could share a deeper meaning
misery is almost like a sister or
companion piece to the shining both
stories feature authors working on a new
project who suffer from the
psychological effects of isolation while
stranded in sidewinder colorado the big
difference is that the shining is a
ghost story while misery has no direct
references to anything supernatural at
all however there are many scenes where
paul and annie try to get into each
other's head and figure out what the
other one is thinking though it's not
evidence that either one is successful
in the mind-reading tactic known as
shining there's also something
interesting about the weapon of choice
in each perspective story
in the book annie uses an axe but in the
movie she uses a mallet whereas in the
shining it's a mallet in the book but in
acts in the movie pomeroy ends up
staying at annie's house where according
to her they were lovers despite him
being 18 years younger at the age of 22.
however it was bad news for him when
annie found out that he'd been lying
about working for the magazine he was
really just planning to sell the
drawings on spec she was also critical
of his work which caused him to laugh at
her
and that may have been the last straw
because annie gave him the axe and
dumped his body in the frozen stream bed
where it stayed for the entire winter
once the stream
thought out the weather carried his
dismembered remains away nearly 27 miles
and he wasn't found until november 1984
a year after his death annie continued
living in relative isolation with her
six hands two cows and her pig
misery she did sometimes get complaints
about her yard from her neighbors the
roidmans but it would seem that with no
hospital to feed her new victims her
homicidal days were behind her but
in february 1987 she would discover a
golden opportunity
on a stormy day in mid to late february
annie went into town to get groceries
and check if the paperbacks of the new
paul sheldon book
misery's child were in yet while her
copy of the book was not ready yet she
would get something much
better and i'm not talking about the
audiobook she ended up coming across a
car crash and because of her nursing
background she can tell that the victim
has the will to live based on the
quality of his screens now in the movie
she eventually admits that she was
stalking paul when the accident occurred
but that's not the case in the book but
i do like to think she knew of his
tradition of finishing his books at the
boldorado hotel and maybe went out of
her way to go past there
the cpr she administered probably saved
his life but because of her obsessive
fandom she makes the decision not to do
the right thing by bringing him to the
hospital but instead
back to her house where she planned to
take care of him on her own
annie already considered herself his
number one fan she had taken a liking to
his work immediately when she discovered
it but because this is where the story
starts this is where
we can shift our focus from annie's
borderline personality disorder to
another classification celebrity worship
syndrome
i'm not a fan of that acronym but unlike
bpd celebrity worship syndrome isn't
officially recognized by the national
institute of mental health but remember
these disorders are just ways for us to
describe a pattern of mental behavior
it's not quite the same as say a virus
which has physical particles that we can
identify but there is still legit
research on celebrity worship syndrome
with studies linking it to increased
levels of anxiety
and depression both of those are also
symptoms of borderline personality
disorder which obviously led me to
speculate in annie's case the two are
linked and i'll discuss that link
later on in her story mr sheldon falls
into a respiratory depression
so annie had him on paid medication and
fed him through an iv
a week and a half later she went into
town where she was finally able to get
her copy of misery's child
paul sheldon writes the misery novels
the very good i'm looking for the latest
one
misery's child i really need that to
complete my collection
and i really think you need to have that
here
i don't know misery i don't have it in
the store but i could probably order it
for you i'm not
interested in waiting what kind of
cockadoody bookstore is this
how could any of you be in a bookstore
when you don't know paul sheldon no
worries man no one takes
i can order it foreign you and two weeks
after the crash she greeted him as he
finally came too
as part of her plan she kept him on a
pain medication called an overall which
worked to her advantage because it made
him drowsy so that he was easy to
control
she knowingly gets him hooked so that
even as he regained his strength
he would always need to stick around to
get his fix of no role she also finds
the manuscript for his next novel
fast cars in his bag and asks if she can
read it when he allows her she
accidentally lets this confession slip
i love you paul
your mind your creativity
that's that's all i meant this is
another possible symptom of the
celebrity worship disorder commonly
referred to as love obsession
where the person may convince themselves
that they're in love with the celebrity
despite
not actually knowing them this famously
happened when a woman convinced herself
that she was the wife of talk show host
david letterman for five years or
perhaps even more cringefully a man with
a youtube account who publicly released
a happy birthday video for bridget west
from the angry grandpa show where he
basically asked her to leave her
boyfriend for him
gotta roll it
bridget west if you liked what you saw
please subscribe to my youtube channel
also in case you're wondering the
original inspiration to make it look
like i'm interested in you
was a vlog back in june called pickle
boy and bridget break up but i
understand that it will humiliate
michael
if you really do break up with him but
it's your choice
oh given annie wilkes a run for her
money there my man
annie reads 40 pages of the manuscript
for fast cars and criticizes it
in particular she's not a fan of the use
of profanity and it causes her to smash
paul's super bowl against the wall
i honestly think this moment is way
ahead of its time because it
demonstrates a rather new symptom of her
disorder which i'll just call
toxic fandom annie is upset that paul is
straying from writing the type of novel
that she wants him to write
just in the last couple years we've seen
this happen with several franchises fans
start to think that they know better
than the artists and they demand a
return to form
and then the artist either decides to
stay the course or cave into the fan's
demands
once in a blue moon the phantom post
changes actually end up working for the
better but it's really not worth
sacrificing all the original ideas that
have been and
probably will continue to be thrown out
thanks to this trend
i'm not saying fan feedback is always a
bad thing but when the suggestions turn
into demands
threats and thinking they know best
that's where it crosses into disease
territory and i'd rather have an artist
try something new and fail
rather than pander to the masses which
almost never yields an interesting
product modern fans use social media to
wage warfare and the artists that they
follow but annie's method of
manipulation involved withholding his
pain medication all afternoon and
eventually making him wash the pills
down with rinse water then the next
morning she repeats her behavior after
reading about her favorite character's
death at the end of misery's child
she throws another tantrum where she
destroys a water pitcher and decides to
leave to get a hold of herself away from
paul
she goes to a property she refers to as
her laughing place an upcountry getaway
inspired by the old children's stories
of braer rabbit and braerfox
at one point she explains sometimes i do
laugh when i go there
but mostly i just scream while she was
there she prayed to god
and when she left the laughing place two
days later she had the idea that she was
supposed to show paul the error of his
past by making him burn his manuscript
she also gets the idea to give him a
chance to redeem himself by forcing him
to write a new book
so on the way back she stops in town and
purchases a typewriter and some paper
she bargains with the shop owner nancy
dartmonger about the price because the
typewriter is missing the letter n
she brings her charcoal grill into the
room and withholds paul's food and
medication until he burns fast cars
which he does after putting up a
struggle that afternoon she sets up a
workstation and tells him to write a new
novel just for her called misery's
return
which was to be her payment for nursing
him of course paul didn't have any
intention of writing another misery
novel but
he doesn't really have a choice he needs
annie's medical help if he wants to
survive and the situation
is representative of what any artist has
to go through in dealing with these
crazy fans
for most artists they have to balance
what they want to do and what the fans
want them to do to survive
that is to make money through their
craft while still expressing themselves
in paul's case the survival aspect is
much more literal annie also tries to
manipulate him into going with her plan
by lying and saying he should be healthy
enough to go out and meet people by the
time that he's done
what she's really doing is sending a
subtle threat do what i say if you want
any chance at surviving
the next morning she shakes paul awake
to serve him breakfast excited for him
to start her masterpiece
paul asked that she'd give him a
different type of paper to work on one
that doesn't smudge and he tries to give
her the idea that there are a lot more
complications in the writing business
than she knows about and i find it
interesting that annie doesn't like
hearing paul call it a business
in the same way that she can't see that
people have both good and bad qualities
she also refuses to acknowledge that her
favorite novels are written for both art
and profit and as you're about to find
out the same concept also applies to
youtube videos
[Music]
[Music]
after throwing a fit over his request
but returning from town with the new
packs of paper annie returns to find
paul in a sweating shivering stage this
gives her the earliest suspicion that
he'd been trying to escape but she's
able to dispel the thought when he tells
her that he'd just been suffering
because of the lack of pain medication
the occurrence would however trigger her
paranoia she had initially begun
experiencing paranoia when she felt that
the whole town was out to get her during
the dragon lady trial so she would put
herself on high alert which was
dangerous for paul her suspicions are
heightened again when she notices that
one of her ceramic figures in the parlor
had been moved and she wonders if paul
had somehow been out of the room but
again
begins to second-guess herself thinking
that she may have been the one to do it
herself
she double-checks to make sure that she
still had the only key to his door and
she did but she still thought that maybe
he had found another way out and her
years of working as a nurse had taught
her to always check her maybes
so she looks in the downstairs bathroom
where all the medication she chips from
her previous hospital jobs was kept
again she had the sense that stuff had
been stirred around but couldn't be sure
that she hadn't moved anything herself
so she decides not to say anything
yet but keep one eye open for more
activity the sequence demonstrates that
she may be crazy but she still has her
wits about her and could be even more
dangerous because of her cleverness
but two days later she had been unable
to find any more evidence that paul had
left the room
so she was about to drop the idea until
she came in to give him his noverl one
afternoon
and felt the doorknob get stuck when she
opened it she heard something rattle
inside the lock but again
she shows her cleverness by not
overreacting until she was sure
this is because if he was sneaking
around she didn't want him to know that
she was onto him she was better off
keeping it a secret so that paul would
continue to be careless and possibly
leave more evidence behind
thus making it less likely that he'd be
able to one day sneak away it was a
constant mind game between the two of
them
so when she heard the lock rattle she
gave him his pills like normal and acted
like nothing was wrong
but again she was back on high alert so
that afternoon when she helped him into
his wheelchair
she realized for the first time that he
was more lively he was able to move his
legs more and his arms were stronger she
had discovered
that he had been hiding his recovery and
thought that he too
was good at keeping secrets so that
night she countered with the move of her
own by giving him a stronger medication
than usual to keep him asleep as she
removed the keyplate from the door and
discovered the bobby pin that he'd used
as his
key that's when she also noticed the
black marks on the door frame as if he'd
bumped the wheelchair into it while
trying to get through
again she decides it's too early to
confront him and thinks it's better if
he's oblivious
a couple days later now past the
three-week mark of her kidnapping him
he's written the first chapter of
misery's return but annie rejects it for
the same reason she detested the clifk
car resolution and rocketman all of
those years ago because the chapter he
came up with wasn't consistent with the
previous entry as paul got back to work
on a second attempt and he secretly
watched him hoping to gather more
information about his escape plan
on march 25th six chapters are complete
and annie agrees that they're fair she
agrees to read his work chapter by
chapter so she can fill in the ends that
he was unable to produce with the
defective typewriter or at least
that's the reason she gets the battle
between paul and annie is a mental game
of chess
if annie's move was to get paul addicted
to the novel so that he needed her his
counter move was to get her addicted to
his writing so that she needed him just
as much
it was also on this day that she gave
the only suggestion about the story that
she would ever give giving him the idea
that maybe one of the characters had not
died but actually had fallen into a coma
induced by a bee sting annie seems to be
very embarrassed to give any input which
is a strange touch because of the
control that she has over the situation
it shows paul that she's still very
sensitive when it comes to the book and
allows him to take one of the few
advantages that he can get over her
but this small win for paul would be
short-lived annie hears a car pulling up
to her house and quickly goes to get her
handcuffs and the only thing she can
find to silence him
a dust rag she locks her prisoner in
place and stuffs the rag in his mouth
not bothering to take the taste of the
chemicals left over on it into
consideration
even though she felt that she had
prevented paul from getting the man's
attention she also had to prevent
the man from noticing paul since the
room does have a window
so she walks him up the driveway to
angle off his possible line of sights
the guy gives her a document that tells
her that she has an overdue property tax
payment and she explodes on him with
anger even though the guy was actually
doing her
courtesy by notifying her she's still
fuming when she comes back inside and
paul helps her calm down by explaining
it to her and offering to pay the fee
with the money left inside of his wallet
annie had basically just forgotten to
pay this fee one of the many examples of
her losing track of small tasks like how
she forgets to turn the calendar page in
paul's room and this isn't a symptom of
the two disorders that we've
already discussed but it does show us
that she's slowly experiencing an
overall mental degradation
with paul's help she's able to go into
town that day and take care of the tax
from march 25th to april 15th they have
a routine going where paul would work on
the novel and annie would mostly work on
maintaining her yard in order to give
nobody a reason to bother her she also
cooked and cleaned she would bring him
dinner at 5 p.m and afterwards
roll into black and white television so
they could watch mash or wkrp
maybe even some mukbang videos
nah not even annie wilkes would watch
that when it got warmer she would take
him out onto the back
porch for some fresh air but on april
15th her good spirits came crashing down
and
despite the dates this one was not tax
related the main symptom associated with
bpd
is huge mood swings and when this
happens victims are more vulnerable for
self-harm and self-destruction
on this day annie's mood was swinging
like a 2015 javier baez we don't exactly
know how she got into such a bad state
but she's described as having a bloody
lip looking like a mess and having some
kind of goo spilled all over her from
what i can gather maybe she was making
breakfast and spilled on herself and got
really depressed and literally beat
herself up over it
she threw paul his pills and when asked
if she was okay she responded
no she left him to go sit down in the
parlor where she repeatedly slapped
herself loud enough for paul to hear
from his room for a manic depressive
person like annie this was the first
sign that she was about to slip into a
deep period of depression which not only
included hurting herself but also
unhealthy binge eating that mirrors her
lack of self-control when it comes to
the consumption of fiction
which comes up again later i think this
also brought back some of her paranoia
about paul escaping the idea of losing
the man she thought she loved made her
even more depressed so she ended up
spying on him all morning through the
keyhole in the door which is
representative of another toxic practice
seen in those with celebrity worship
syndrome something that we've seen quite
a lot in recent years with youtube
celebrities invasion of privacy there
has long been an issue for celebrities
where paparazzi would try to capture
every detail of their lives and while i
don't think invading the private portion
of someone's life is ever a good thing
we've seen it change
from celebrity obsessed individuals
simply being the market for tabloid
magazines to people tracking down
celebrities home addresses
and showing up themselves or worse
setting a horrible example for their
kids by bringing them to ambush their
favorite creators at home
back in the day with traditional media
celebrities it was an issue but less of
an issue
because they could just hire private
security and they were protected but now
with youtube and tick tock we have a lot
of very young people who become very
famous without the wealthiness that used
to come with it
so you know the merch store is always
the reason i bring that up with paul
is he has to deal with something similar
he is rich but because he's at the mercy
of his captor he has no way of
protecting his privacy against annie and
she sees him through the keyhole getting
into his wheelchair to write and
confirming her suspicions about him
faking how weak he really was this would
lead to another outburst where annie's
willingness to let him live
comes to an end
before confronting her disobedient
prisoner again annie goes down into the
basement to clear out the rat traps
because it had been rainy and the rats
tend to come into the cellar when it
rains
she finds one that is injured but still
alive and brings it up when she goes to
see paul
the reason she does this is to draw the
comparison between paul's situation
and the rats they're both captives of
annie and because of their injuries
they're unable to escape she explains
that a rat in a trap thinks it wants to
live
as we do paul as we do we think we know
so much but we really don't know any
more than a rat in a trap a rat with a
broken back that thinks it still wants
to live
notice the wording she's including
herself in that too because she's aware
of her severe depression that is making
her miserable as well
she crushes the rat in her hand and
likewise offers to go get her gun and do
the same to paul and herself
paul's only saving grace is to say that
he first wants to finish the book and
she agrees that that's the only thing
she still wants to see and she
mindlessly licks the rat's blood off her
fingers as she spoke
which is pretty disgusting and i think
it's there to show us how comfortable
annie is with carnage and make her
threats feel that much more real and
scary
before leaving she wants to keep track
of if paul is moving around the house
while she's gone
she plucks out several hairs from her
head and tapes them up around the house
on doors
on her scrapbook that documents all of
her victims cabinets drawers and more
this way she could check which threads
were broken when she got back and
theoretically see exactly where paul had
been
and what he had gone through she goes
off to her laughing place again
and again does more praying than
laughing because of the snow she has to
put chains on her tires to get back down
the road she leaves to come back on
april 17th even though the conditions
were very dangerous
but she was not afraid thinking that god
would guide her i'm guessing that she
has not seen carrie
she almost slid off the road twice at
one point going all-time traveler at
silver dollar city and doing a full 360
degree spin while traveling down the
slope
then around midnight her car got stuck
in a snow bank but she was lucky enough
to get a hand from a public works crew
that was able to free her
so she probably was quite confident that
god was actually guiding her on this
trip she stopped off on route 9 to see
if she could see paul's crashed car
but it was gone which was a relief for
her because she wouldn't have to worry
about anyone finding it and coming to
look for him for a while longer
she finally made it back at 4am and
finds her victim fast asleep
she comes back and inspects everywhere
she had set up her hairs finding many of
the threads broken
proving that paul had been around the
house she also checked upstairs on her
dresser which would have been impossible
for paul to reach with his broken legs
and finds that her hairs have supposedly
been completely removed it could be that
they just weren't set up perfectly and
they fell down on their own but i would
guess that it could be related to her
aforementioned memory problems she
probably planned to set up the threads
on her dresser but never actually did it
but because she knew he'd been out of
the room she blames him for that as well
she also realizes that the butcher knife
in the kitchen was missing
so while he's asleep she searches around
under the bed where she finds that and
some pills that he'd been storing there
this came as a surprise to her and she
must have decided that she'd seen
enough she had to put an end to his
rummaging around before he found a way
to get an upper hand
so to do so she turned to a technique
originating in south africa
as paul woke up that morning she
injected him with a pre-op shot
she reveals that she found the bobby pin
that he used to escape the first time
the broken
threads and the butcher's knife which
she angrily throws at the wall where it
sticks like a dart
she explains that paul's tricks won't
fly by her she's been a nurse for 10
years
this is another example of her memory
issues or her losing her mind because if
you were paying attention in the
beginning of this video you may remember
she became a nurse in 1966 which was
actually 21 years beforehand
she asked how many times he left the
room he insists it was three times but
she believes that it's more
i guess fellows like you must get so
used to lying for a living that you just
can't stop doing it in real life
but that's all right paul because the
principle doesn't change if you are out
seven times or seventy or
seventy times seven the principle
doesn't change and neither does
the response the seventy times seven
thing is not another brand new reference
because they didn't exist yet
but rather a biblical reference towards
the belief in eternal forgiveness from
god who is supposed to forgive a man's
sins not seven times not 70 times seven
times but always so annie is basically
saying she doesn't care how many times
paul's been out she's still gonna punish
him with a process called hobbling
paul do you know about the early days at
the kimberley diamond mines
do you know what they did to the native
workers who stole diamonds
if they caught them they had to make
sure they could go on working but they
also had to make sure they could never
run away
the operation was called hobbling she
plans to dismember his foot using very
makeshift tools she has a bottle of
betadine to disinfect the wound which
she slathers over his leg then brings
out the axe she also has a freaking
propane
torch that didn't make the movie she
chops the axe down into his ankle
causing excruciating pain but annie
after taking out over 40 people in her
lifetime showed no
sympathy and reared back again to cut
clean through his ankle
that's where the blowtorch comes in she
uses that to burn his stump to a crisp
thus cauterizing the wound this causes
the bed sheet to catch fire and she's
prepared with a bucket of water to dump
over everything
it seems that annie then started to
realize how dangerous her barbaric
torture method was she told him he'd be
fine
even as he was screaming from the worst
pain imaginable but she sounded nervous
as she did so and seemed to be looking
around the room
i think she realized that the procedure
had come way too close to killing him
and she was worried that she'd never get
to read the end of her book because of
it
this fear kept up for the next week he
was in a semi-comatose state and she
wouldn't allow him to go back to his
work on the novel when he started to
come out of it
because she was still very nervous that
he was on the brink of death when he did
go back to his writing she collected his
work at the end of every day eager to
get her fix of fiction
if anywhere around today she would
likely be one of those people who
exercised no self-control when it comes
to the binge release strategies seen on
certain streaming platforms where an
entire season of a show will be released
at once
earlier i mentioned that when she went
into the manic episode it was
accompanied by the binge eating of
unhealthy snacks
and i briefly mentioned that it shows
her lack of self-control which is
paralleled by her lack of self-control
and consuming her favorite media so when
she comes in to try to bribe paul into
telling her the entire rest of the story
it's no coincidence that she uses ice
cream sundaes to try to do so
paul wisely chooses not to tell her the
ending though since the anticipation for
the book was the only thing keeping him
alive
as the spring season was winding down
annie must have been in a particularly
bad mental state
and when she heard paul complaining
about the missing n key on the
typewriter she wanted to give him
something new to worry about
and came back with the disinfectant a
syringe and an electric knife
ready to perform another operation
after paul's complaint about the
typewriter annie stormed into the
kitchen in another bipolar episode she
was throwing around
objects and screaming she came back into
the room and jabbed the syringe into
paul
it caused him to become drowsy and
defenseless and once again she poured on
the betadine and held down his hand
as he screamed and pleaded with her
after cutting off the thumb with her
electric knife she took it back with her
into the kitchen and got to work on
baking a cake
this was part of her plan to remind paul
who was really in charge she felt he was
getting too comfortable when he started
asking for things again so this was her
psychotic way of setting the record
straight
she stuck his loose thumb into the
birthday cake like a candle and brought
it into the room singing happy birthday
although it was not actually paul's
birthday he got the idea when she told
him
if you promise to be good paul you can
have a piece of birthday cake but you
won't have to eat any of the special
candle
from there she only gets weirder and
crazier which may have had something to
do with the fact that paul was closing
in on finishing the book and she knew
their time was coming to an end one way
or another
over a month later a car appears at her
house before she has the chance to gag
paul again
and she hears shattering glass and
immediately knows that he's trying to
get the person's attention
she grabs a sharpened cross you know
something that everybody just has lying
around and goes out to discover it's a
police officer the guy whose name was
dwayne kushner was stunned to have found
paul and he didn't even notice annie
before she marched out and stabbed him
in the back and stomach several times
sending him crashing to the ground she
leaves him barely alive then comes and
finishes the job with her rideable
lawnmower
using it to run over his arm and head
it's the 9th annual dallas mower expo
be there as the biggest names in moore's
hedges and clippers hunting technology
seeking oil paintings oil paintings
seeking don't miss the dallas mower expo
annie spends the afternoon casually
cleaning up the body and erasing any
evidence singing she'll be coming around
the mountain as she did so i kind of
wish this was in the movie because it
shows how doing something so vile can be
a source of happiness for her and i
think if done right it could have been
really creepy
in the same way as jack reciting the
three little pigs nursery rhyme in the
shining she knows that eventually more
cops will come looking for kushner so
she devises a plan to give paul a little
more time to finish the novel she
doesn't care what happens to her after
that she starts by dragging a mattress
down to the cellar and brings paul down
there so that he can't alert the police
if they come back again while she goes
to hide the police car at her laughing
place there's also an interesting
conversation that takes place with paul
where we find out that she actually
believes that she's not
crazy she sees herself as a good
samaritan because she saved paul's life
and he said i was raised better even if
you weren't you're lucky i didn't cut
off your man gland
i thought of it you know yikes she then
goes on to explain her entire plan to
him she's gonna hide the car in the shed
bury the cop and ride her ex-husband's
trail bike to get back
she'll leave a note on the door saying
she went off to a ceramic show in
steamboat heaven but if they ask her
about it later she'll say that she slept
in her car rather than a hotel so that
nobody asks her to produce receipts
she also says that she'll be keeping the
deceased officer's gun in her purse so
if paul tries to scream whenever the
cops do show back up she could
reasonably take them both out before
they're able to react
she does all of that the next morning
and the day after the cops do show up as
expected
she explains to them that the first
officer came around looking for paul
right as she was about to leave and she
told him that she did recognize the man
in the photo because it was her favorite
writer she also explains that she
supposedly offered the guy a cold pepsi
on his way out
and that he had taken it with him and
danny had planted a pepsi bottle with
his fingerprints on it a couple miles
down the road to make it look like he
had passed her house safely
she's able to send these new cops on
their way without incidents but it
wasn't long before news broke that the
dragon lady was under investigation once
again
three days later a news crew shows up
which especially got under annie's skin
because the media was probably her least
favorite part about when she was on
trial in denver for her actions as the
head maternity nurse
she fires a warning shot with her gun to
scare them away but when she comes back
in her old paranoia about the town being
out to get her returns and sends her
into another manic depressive episode
scratching and slapping herself to the
point of drawing blood more police show
up the next day and they inquire about
the injuries she'd given herself so she
tells them that she'd scratched herself
during a bad
dream her secret was unraveling and she
predicted that they'd be back before
long with the search warrant
the next day gawkers from in town came
by to look at the house which continued
to unnerve her at one point a car full
of teenagers comes onto the driveway to
make fun of the dragon lady and she
furiously threatens to shoot them if
they don't leave if only it was the late
2000s she would have known that all you
have to do is tuck in your clothes and
strike a violent pose
considering that even just being
bothered by her neighbors the roidmins
who lived down the road got her in a
rage before
this new wave of attention was really
getting to her but she's able to get
through it when paul delivers the good
news misery's return should be done
the next evening when the morning of the
big day arrived annie excitedly came in
to bring him his breakfast and pain
medication just as she had when he first
started the book so i'm gonna use
the same exact footage right here later
that day she brings in a caviar dish in
celebration of the book's completion she
had never had caviar before and when she
tried it she didn't like the taste i'm
not entirely sure how to interpret that
it could be king leaving his readers a
clue about who would win and who would
lose or it could be something deeper
than that
she informs him that when the last word
is written his favorite bottle of
champagne will be waiting for him and he
requests to be allowed to practice
one other ritual he has for finishing a
book smoking his cigarette
although she finds smoking to be
disgusting she allows it as long as
she's out of the room when she doesn't
she's probably in a charitable mood out
of excitement to finally find out how
the story ends
she brings the smoke in the match into
the room around noon and leaves him to
complete the book until he calls her in
to read the final chapters but as soon
as she gets into the room she knows
something is wrong when she smells
lighter fluid she freezes and sees paul
holding the lit match over a soaked
stack of papers he sets it on fire and
that hurts her more than anything he
could have possibly done to her because
reading this book was the only thing
that she had left to live for
she screamed and rushed to try to put
out the flames in her delusional state
she still felt that some of it could be
salvaged she keeps saying not misery not
misery another sign that she was living
more in the fictional world than the
real one she had never shown this kind
of compassion or care for any of her
victims
as she's trying to save the burning
pages she doesn't notice paul lift up
the typewriter and smash it down upon
the center of her back
this knocks her down into the flames and
she screams even louder as her skin
burns
she hollers at paul that she's going to
kill him but she trips over the
typewriter ironically the thing that she
cheaped out on and caused so many issues
for paul including the loss of his thumb
was finally coming back to bite annie he
falls on top of her and she struggles to
claw her way out under his waves then he
begins to stuff the burning piles of ash
into her mouth choking her just as she
had nearly choked him with the dust rag
eventually she's able to buck him off of
her but she ends up tripping on the
typewriter a second time
i've heard of tripping on your words but
this is ridiculous this time her head
slams against the mantelpiece and she
goes down and knocking her out for some
time
she comes to and sees paul trying to get
away but again her previous actions come
back to bite her she's unable to hold on
to his leg with no foots to grab onto
and he gets away and closes the door
behind him but desperate to have her
revenge on the man who killed her misery
not
once but twice she makes her way to the
door and reaches her fingers underneath
to try to grab his clothes but is
unsuccessful at holding on to him
and passes out again when she wakes up
she's able to remove the burnt paper
from her throat and she has some time to
get a hold of herself and try to make
one last go at trying to bring paul down
with her
she's pretty sure that he's still in the
house because her car is still there and
as far as she could tell nobody had come
to rescue him
the doors to the outside were also all
locked making it very unlikely that he'd
be able to get out on his own
she jumps out the guest room window and
makes her way to the barn where she
would pick out a tool to exact her
revenge
she grabs her chainsaw and with it in
her hand while making her way out of the
barn
she collapsed for the final time police
later discovered her and determined that
she had succumbed to her fractured skull
it was the typewriter that had really
done her in in the end annie would be
known by the community as far more than
a stalker fan of a romance novelist the
community would eventually discover her
scrapbook and trail of more than 40
crimes but to paul sheldon who had dealt
with letters from many obsessed fans in
the past
running into the craziest of them was
his worst nightmare and for the world
famous author stephen king annie was a
combination of every uncomfortable fan
experience
wrapped up and taken to the worst
possible scenario there are many
more characters you have to understand
to have a full grasp of the stephen king
universe so click that playlist on the
left to hear about the histories of his
other characters
and if you love horror remember to
subscribe to cz's world for new horrors
every week ring that death bell for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we stay inside